I had a I'll keep my remarks brief but I
had an extraordinary experience at the
end of March I attended a memorial
service at a chapel at Fort Myer and it
was a memorial service for the
extraordinary man that we honor tonight
I think by having a program around his
remarkable career and at that memorial
service there were representatives of
the CIA other agencies and of the Polish
Embassy and we were all there to honor
one man who in a sense spoke had lived
for both our countries in many ways and
it was quite a moving tribute to him he
had been cremated the urn with his
contents was at the altar it was a mass
and banding it was his Polish army
colors and his barracks cap the eulogy
was given by the head of the clandestine
service from CIA Jim pavatt and sitting
in the front row was George Tenet
the DCI it was a remarkable honoring of
this remarkable man the follow even
another ceremony at the Polish Embassy
and that too honored him as a Polish
Patriot the keynote speaker was as big
knife Kaczynski the former National
Security Advisor who spoke of kuklinski
as truly a Polish a patriot and had a
historic figure and I think I know some
of you know the story better than others
some of you lived the story but I think
all of you can't help but being moved by
the extraordinary life that kuklinski
led and his contribution at the last
years of his life to helping keep us
free of both nuclear war and of tyranny
let me quickly introduce the speakers
and then I just had one thing to share
with you on your on your left been wiser
is of course the author of the book
since 1997 been wiser has been a New
York Times reporter covering legal
issues and terrorism he covered the spot
the terror trials of the 1993 bombing of
the World Trade Center prior to that he
was with The Washington Post for some 18
years he was on the investigative staff
this matter was of course Carl Woodward
Bob Woodward excuse me Bob Woodward he
would be upset of I got his name wrong
Bob Woodward so that was his training
and background and I think that gives
you a sense of the ban next is Aris
Pappas a a senior officer in CIA before
his retirement involved with both
analytical and operational issues he was
a member of the senior intelligence
service since then he has participated
in a variety of advisory committees on
terrorism founded a company which of
which he is the principal for homeland
security and he is on one of the two
Kirk committees have you have heard of
those looking into the intelligence
performance before the Iraq war and Dave
fortín de verdun a 35-year career in CIA
iris had I believe about 34 35 for those
of you who have read the book Dave for
Dhin was of course Daniel and he is a
remarkable figure both he and kuklinski
are painted in such vivid colors in the
story David was a throughout much of his
career it was he was an Operations
Officer or case officer
he served in some six countries over
that 18 year span and was the chief of
station which as you know is the senior
CIA representative in both as I recall
David Warsaw Athens and one of the
station Vienna how could I forget Vienna
and he will speak to that issue so we
are in a sense laying this out in
chronological order
I think we've all been struck by been
Weiser's approach I will not take do not
want to take any of his Thunder away but
I would like to just read one passage as
we open tonight he is speaking in the in
the introduction and he said more
recently as he sets the stage there have
been renewed debate about the
effectiveness of the CIA's human
intelligence capabilities particularly
since the September not the September
11th terror attacks and the Bush
administration's war in Iraq the
kolinsky case tells a different story
showing how human intelligence
operations can succeed when they are
handled with scrupulous care and
imagination the operation reveals the
side of the CIA that is not often seen
of case officers who joined the agency
because they were attracted by the
excitement and intrigue of undercover
work and by the idea of public service
the CIA is the face America first offers
people who like kuklinski are inspired
by Western ideals to the extent CIA
fails to carry out such operations the
United States loses a powerful means of
understanding nation's regimes and
groups that are hostile to the West's
been wiser please help me welcome Ben
wiser
we get out of your way actually thank
you very much Peter and thank you very
much for coming this evening it's it's
it's great to be here and I must say to
start that I do miss Rashard kuklinski
he passed away a couple months ago right
after the book was published and but he
did have a chance to read the book and
liked it and and I miss him a lot I've
entered a guess that few people have
really ever heard of richard kuklinski
in the United States maybe even in this
room before before recently and I had
never heard of him either that may be a
mark of how well this operation was kept
secret for so long he's not he was not
famous and in some ways is still not but
kuklinski came to my attention in the
late 80s when I read a couple paragraphs
about him and a book by my my boss Bob
Woodward when I worked at the Washington
Post
Bob had written a book about the CIA and
had devoted a few pages to kuklinski who
at the time Bob had reported delivered
the martial law plans to the United
States in 1981 this these were the plans
by the communist leadership of Poland to
crush the Solidarity worker movement in
Poland which ultimately did occur in in
in 1981
Kuklinski later was exfiltrated to the
United States and not much else was
known I was intrigued by the passage
that I read and decided to write a
letter to kuklinski and like a good
journalist I wasn't sure where to send
it so I just send it to the CIA and I
said you know deliver it and they did
and my understanding later is that they
advised him not to talk to me but he did
agree to sit down with me I told him in
the letter that I was just curious about
what had motivated him to do what he had
done little of it that I even knew we
then met in what the agency would call a
safe house it was just a hotel room in
Virginia but we we met for a week with
the public affairs people of the agency
nearby and rashard laid out for me
something I had not known which was that
in addition to providing the CIA with
the information about martial law in
advance of that happening he had worked
and cooperated with the CIA for almost
nine years
for about nine years and had delivered a
lot more than just that as I later
confirmed he delivered elements of the
Soviet war plans for Europe the
locations and specifications of bunkers
hidden bunkers for the Soviet and Warsaw
Pact leadership in Bulgaria the Soviet
Union and Poland details of weapons
systems in some cases that the United
States had not even seen yet and a great
deal of other information as well and
after talking to him at great length and
deciding there would be a wonderful news
story to write I headed off to Poland
and was able to sit down with general
Yara's else key and other generals who
rashard had worked for when he was in
Poland and who ultimately he betrayed I
also sat down with Dave Fortin and
others from the CIA who gave me the
perspective of the agency on the case
after writing a couple articles in The
Washington Post which were reproduced in
Polish in Poland I was fascinated by the
debate those articles contributed to in
Poland about whether kuklinski had been
a traitor or or a hero for betraying
something and that's something in who
Klinsky x' mind was the Polish communist
leadership and the Soviet leadership
which in his view had totally destroyed
his country those who criticized him in
Poland said that he had betrayed the
Polish army and thus was a traitor and
indeed when I met with kuklinski in the
United States he was under under he we
had to meet in secret because the poles
actually at the time had a warrant after
his arrest he had been convicted in
absentia in Poland and sentenced to
death that sentence was ultimately
reduced to 25 years but he was a wanted
man I decided it would be fun and
interesting to write a book and after
Koontz Key told me that he had no plans
to write his own book I set out to do so
the most important thing to me about
writing the book and that is the book we
finally produced was to try to obtain
the internal archives of the CIA about
the case everything I had done up to
that point was based on people's
memories and they were good memories and
good recollections but my hope was to
get a essentially a contemporaneous
account of what he had told the agency
of
he had learned and had passed on to the
United States and what the agency was
telling him through this operation Dave
also had told me that during the nine
years that this operation had existed
that he and kuklinski had exchanged very
personal letters throughout the period
every several months sometimes longer
Dave knew that kuklinski had nobody he
could confide in about what he was doing
and so he would confide in Daniel which
is how kolinsky knew of David so through
a complicated set of negotiations with
the CIA which we do explain in the
introduction to the book I ultimately
was able to get access to the internal
operational file a lot of it from the
book and Peter earnest who's here
actually was my researcher for that the
material was was fascinating it was it
was roughly 700 pages of raw
contemporaneous material it included the
letters that Dave and Rashard exchanged
none of which had ever been written with
the ax thought that they'd be read
outside I think outside the few closed
group of people that even knew that he
existed and what he was doing and I
ultimately was able to use this material
to do further reporting what was
interesting about this case is it when I
began this project in the mid 1990s the
case itself was only about 15 or 16
years over it had ended in 81 and it was
quite recent and in CIA years and the
the and this was one reason why there
was some hesitation I think about
whether the access would be granted in
the first place the material was was was
raw in some places and and and
absolutely fascinating and I'll give you
an example of the kind of thing that was
in there that allowed me then to do
further reporting and resulted in a
section of the book that for example
I'll now explain in 1980 December
Kuklinski provided the United States
with a critical piece of information as
many of you may know there was great
fear after the beginning of the
Solidarity movement in 1981 that the
Soviet Union might invade Poland as they
had done Czechoslovakia earlier there
were troops amassing on the borders
outside Pollin and there was great
question and great concern in the US
government about whether an invasion
might occur what was making it harder
for the United States
really know was that there was bad
weather over Central and Eastern Europe
and our satellites were actually unable
to track things as well as we usually
like to do and we simply didn't know in
the end what the intentions were of the
Soviet Union Kuklinski who by then had
risen to a very senior level on the
Polish General Staff a a colonel who had
been born in Poland and had been a proud
member of the Polish army but who in
1980 and 1972 had become so repulsed by
what he felt the Soviets had done to his
country that he decided to reach out to
the United States
Kuklinski learned that this that the
Soviet Union had finally prepared plans
and and was ready was in a readiness
position to launch an invasion and he
actually had the date and that and and
when this readiness would occur in early
December and complete details of how
such an invasion would take place as he
often did he carefully wrote this
information on three pieces of paper he
tended to write and block printing in
Polish folded the paper up very tight
stuck it inside an old glove dipped it
in grease and did everything else he
could to make this glove the most
repugnant item that would be lying on
the ground that night in Warsaw he
wanted nobody to pick this up but deep
inside this was was the information and
he was trying to provide and then as he
often did when he was going to leave
information for the CIA there was he
left a signal and got a return signal
that an exchange would take place that
night and cuckoos he then set out on
what we call in the book and what what
what is historically called a
surveillance detection run in in some
cases these last several hours and
they're done by both people like who
Klinsky as well as CIA officers who want
to make sure that they're not being
watched or followed by by anybody when
he was satisfied that he was on his own
he headed out to the location where this
particular item would be left he had
been instructed in this case to leave it
under a streetlight on the visa la
strada the main boulevard that went
through warsaw it was the winter it was
December and kuklinski knew that night
it was going to snow but he also knew
that when he left it on the street
roughly 9:30 or so or nine o'clock there
would still be a short enough period of
time before the CIA officer who was
gonna pick it up a get there and that
whatever snow fell it shouldn't cover
the glove he had to get this information
to the US immediately he drove he he
pretended he was skidding his car and to
the side of the road it was as I say
snowy night got out went around brushed
snow off the front of his window but as
he walked around his car he just let
slip from his hand this item this glove
under the streetlight and kuklinski once
told me he had learned and had been been
told that sometimes that darkest place
is under the lantern and and in his view
this was the place that he would leave
this information then he drove away and
it happened that this location was not
far from the rear of his house and he
actually went home parked his car and
walked behind his house to watch and
make sure that the information was
picked up that same evening a CIA
officer in the Warsaw station who we
named as Ted Gilbertson in the book
that's a pseudonym for an actual officer
who's now retired who may be in the
audience I'm not sure he said he might
not set out on his own surveillance
detection run because he knew that he
had to be at that location at 10 o'clock
to pick up a piece of information he
suspected had to do with the the
potential invasion but he didn't in fact
know what was coming but he knew that
there was something important Koontz
gets left a signal saying we've got to
get this information out to the agency
and Gilbertson drove on a several hour
the surveillance detection run make
certain in his mind that he was not
being followed knew the snow was coming
down but felt comfortable that he would
be able to get to the spot where he
needed to be timed it just perfectly so
that about ten o'clock he was driving
down the same big Boulevard where kook
Lenski had been earlier saw the
streetlights coming into view and
counted to the point that he knew he had
to stop he too skidded his car onto the
side of the road to look like he had
just skidded there was not much traffic
on the road that night he got out
inspected the car to make sure that
nothing had gone wrong to certainly make
it appear that that was why he was there
and then started looking in the ground
but the problem was that as he had
driven to that location a snowplow had
gone right in front of him he had seen
that snowplow and and and he was
horrified because the snowplow had
created a snow
where he thought only a couple inches of
snow at worst would be so he got down on
his hands and knees and starts reaching
into the snow and digging deep and it
took several minutes and and he finally
found the item now all this is was
reduced to a single little note in the
archive that that we found in which that
night years ago this officer wrote a
note describing exactly what he had been
doing and how he was reaching in and how
he finally felt something crinkle in his
hands and it turned out that was the
glove so we used that that that note and
and of course interviewing him to
reconstruct that moment then we're able
to use then we were able to use the
archive to show what happened next
Gilbertson took the information that
took the glove back to his hotel back to
his apartment that night he could not
drive to the Warsaw station at that hour
because that would not be his routine
and it would set off alarm bells the
next morning he took the glove and the
and the few pieces of paper which he had
already translated him under his pillows
to the CIA station in Warsaw which was
in the embassy and the station there
cabled it to Washington and through
interviews with dr. Brzezinski and
others we've been able to track and we
do in the book how that information went
from the CIA to dr. Burzynski who is the
National Security Advisor who walked it
into the Oval Office and gave it to the
President of the United States so from a
dirty greased-up glove on the streets of
Warsaw to the president's desk and it
was a classic piece of how human
intelligence worked and in this case it
clearly led to some results the White
House with the concern that already
existed had already sent a message on
the hotline to to the Kremlin's warning
bridge they have not not to invade or
serious consequences would occur and
after getting this detail from kuklinski
what public announcements were made more
messages were sent out and there was no
invasion so this is just one of the
examples of how we were able to pull the
archive and interviews with the actual
people involved to reconstruct these
this era this book tries to do two
things it tries to show how a human
intelligence operation was handled
successfully and what mode and the other
side of the story
is kuklinski himself what motivated a
man who was thriving and doing extremely
well on the Polish army and in the
General Staff to decide to cross the
line I've concluded that that he was
really a brilliant thinker who was very
much ahead of his time that back in the
late 60s and early 70s he rose so high
up in the in the General Staff and had
become the liaison with the Warsaw Pact
command in Moscow that he got very close
to the real secrets and he figured out
and he learned that the Soviet plans for
war in Europe were offensive not
defensive in nature and he also figured
out because of what his job was which
was to plan this war that the main
victim of such a world would be Poland
and without getting into all the detail
in the book he figured out and knew that
the war plans would have pushed the
Soviet troops the Soviet troops would
have pushed westward across Europe the
United States would have responded to
such an attack with nuclear weapons and
they would not have landed in Russia or
in the Soviet Union's westernmost
republics they would have landed in
Poland in in in almost entirely and
kuklinski in 1972 in an extraordinary
decision decided to reach out to the
United States Army and bond and and and
and he just has told me and I'm
convinced having read the archival
material that it's right that that he
had this idea that Poland did not have
to be enslaved forever and that that
that there could be a way that that
might that might change and so to the
extent that that he was ahead of his
time I feel that he he he is a historic
figure as Brzezinski has said there's
very little that I could write as a
writer that's better than the writing
the kuklinski himself wrote as he
explained his motivations which is
detailed in the book but I was very
honored to have known him and I felt
privileged to have been able to write
the story thanks
it's it's a great privilege to be able
to be here this evening to talk about
this it's not a case to me it's a person
it's an individual I'm aware and I want
to share with you the sacrifices that he
made as an individual and I want to talk
to you about the significance of the
work that he did for Poland for his
family and for the United States indeed
for the free world my participation in
this as an analyst does not involve
rooting around looking for gloves in
Warsaw and so on and so forth the
operators do that and you'll hear more
about more and more about that and
indeed most of the book is about that
kind of exciting and very realistic and
very real work that has to be done
overseas by these brave people as an
analyst my job is to sit back in
Washington and I represent many many
analysts who are involved in this effort
and take the information that's provided
and try to put it into a context so that
it is useful so our job was to try and
understand the situation my
participation in this entire effort I
think falls into three phases one is my
association with a source the second is
my association with a colleague and the
third is my lasting association with a
friend I say source first when I joined
the CIA in 1975 little by little as you
approach your analytic endeavors you are
given access to more and more sensitive
information and it's great that's what
analysts like to do they like to know
more they like to delve in and find out
what's going on indeed one of the
attractions of being an analyst as
opposed to a case officer is the the
ability to look at this stuff that's
coming in from all of those cases
and trying to put them into a context so
you feel like you really know what's
going on you think you're not always
right but you feel that way it's a good
thing in here and there was this source
and the source had a very special
compartment that's what they call them
compartments and each one of these
compartments is carefully segregated and
not everybody can see all of the
compartments it depends on what you're
working on
but I was working on the Soviet military
the Warsaw Pact military my job was to
look at what they called theater forces
from from the Soviet Union not strategic
forces which are the intercontinental
ballistic missiles again as an analyst
my feeling was that if we ever made a
mistake on the strategic forces that'd
be no after-action report so therefore
not very interesting I looked at the
theater forces and I was given access to
this body of information that was coming
in we as analysts would have no idea
none zero who the person was indeed
persons indeed whether it was technical
how this information was being obtained
was not necessarily clear to us but the
fact that it was being obtained meant
everything to our ability to do the job
that we were given to do and what was
that job and what did this man
contribute it may sound trivial but
think about it he contributed to our
ability to understand what was happening
and understand what might happen next he
provided us the context that we were
able to use to recognize what was
happening in the world most mistakes
that are called intelligence failures
most policy mistakes are the result of
some misinterpretation of data some
misinterpretation of intention some
misinterpretation of what somebody
else's objectives might be and the
intelligence is used for the purpose of
apprising the government the President
of the United States the National
Security Advisor and others of what is
going on and what did kuklinski give us
he gave us that touchstone he gave us
the ability to take all of the technical
information that was being collected on
the Soviet Union on the Warsaw Pact and
put it in a context that allowed us to
recognize why these things were
happening and understanding why they're
happening gives you the ability to deal
with
days when you don't really know when
you're not getting the technical
information when you're not getting all
the latest data but you get some
momentum through that understanding of
context and was this important
absolutely absolutely
it was important from the context of our
ability to confront the Soviet machine
it was important from our to our ability
to understand why that machine was
deployed the way it was it was important
to our ability to understand how that
machine might be used against us and
therefore by extension it was absolutely
vital to our ability to make
recommendations to the military in
particular end to the policy organs of
the United States as to how to deal with
that that imposing imposing threat been
mentioned the fact that Colonel
kuklinski saw the threat to Poland it
was unmistakable
and if I may lay it out for just a
moment for you imagine if you will
Poland here in the center and from your
perspective Germany over here the
western districts of the Soviet Union
over here the basic plan lays out like
this in Germany NATO on one side the
forward echelon of the Soviet forces
buttress by the East Germans to Czechs
underneath that the Hungarians
underneath that all facing to the east
to the west that would have been the
first clash of forces the first
strategic Escalon of Soviet forces aided
by the East Europeans with NATO
they were about evenly matched in size
and capability the trump card for the
Soviet Union was the presence of an
entire additional set of forces that
would come out of the Western military
districts of the Soviet Union crossed
through Poland and engage the by then
depleted NATO forces NATO had no
reserves NATO did not have a second
strategic echelon to match the Soviet
force and so therefore this second
strategic echelon was absolutely vital
to any projection of conflict in Western
Europe that force would not be struck in
the Western Soviet
in the western districts of the Soviet
Union East yes western districts in the
Soviet Union principally because they
would begin to move upon the declaration
of war or upon mobilization immediately
preceding war which means that by the
time we got to striking them they would
be in transit across Poland Poland would
have turned into a butcher shop
what kuklinski was able to do apart from
the larger effort of allowing us to
recognize how these plans laid out how
it was all going to work and what we
could do to intercede was by providing
us with the degree of detail with the
degree of insight as to how those forces
were planning to transit Poland we could
target those forces much more precisely
and by targeting them much more
precisely do a much better job of
affecting you know their disruption and
also by the way a much better job of
limiting unnecessarily large casualties
because of lack of information colonel
kuklinski provided us with all of that
colleague when Colonel kuklinski came
out I was introduced to him very very
shortly after his his exfiltration
largely because one of my Jobs was to
deal with the question of the Polish
imposition of martial law we knew they
were planning it Chronicle Klinsky was
involved in that planning if not the key
planner and was providing us with that
information
it was my account I was reading that
material on as soon as it arrived in
Washington we knew that the poles were
planning it we didn't know when it might
happen in my first interview with him we
were able to determine precisely the
Polish schedule for this not to say the
specific date but the fact that we knew
the poles were had already undertaken a
decision to engage in martial law I
wrote a note represented in Ben's book
which I believe went to the president
that night indicating that there is
unlikely to be much warning past this
point of any actual imposition of
martial law what we did with Colonel
kuklinski and the reason I use the word
colleague is he was such a rare asset
in terms of his background in training
he was a graduate of the voter she loved
staff academy in Moscow he had hobnobbed
worked with and was professionally adept
at the highest levels of the Warsaw Pact
and the Soviet Union and as a result his
thinking was thinking that we could
still use as if he were in place his
access to the documents no longer there
his access to actually what was
happening over there no longer there but
remember we had lots of abilities to
steal simple secrets what we were
lacking always was that ability to put
these things into context and Colonel
kuklinski could still put those things
into context for us four years after his
departure so instead of giving him a new
life and setting him up as a used car
dealer in Baltimore or something like
this
Colonel kuklinski was used by us
analysts CIA to continue to deal with
questions of how would the Soviet
General Staff respond to this question
how would the Soviet General Staff look
at this issue what would be the kinds of
problems that they would face in
overcoming this this set of operational
difficulties all of these things were
tremendously vital to us we were also
able to take Colonel kuklinski down and
meet with senior US advisors generals
and so on there's a marvelous episode in
the book for those of you that haven't
read it where we took Colonel kuklinski
down to meet general al gray who is the
commander of US Marine Forces Atlantic
at the time and was very soon to be the
Commandant of the Marine Corps it was a
wonderful session it was supposed to
last about two hours early in the
morning after all this man was a
three-star Marine general his staff told
us not to be upset if he left early
because he had pressing things to do the
session started at 8:00 o'clock at noon
general gray pulled out his wallet told
his aide to get everybody sandwiches he
wasn't even going to take a lunch break
at 4:00 o'clock in the afternoon he
dismissed the rest of his staff he told
Colonel kuklinski myself and my partner
Jim Simon that we were to return to our
hotel get rid of the monkey suits and
returned to his quarters for the rest of
the evening where general gray grilled
up steaks on a barbecue and we wound up
sitting up in his
in his study until two or three in the
morning as I recalled sipping brandy
smoking cigars and swapping tall tales
about military history and so on and so
forth Colonel kolinsky was a
professional military officer and every
time we took him to touch with meet with
and speak with American professional
military the click was like that they
could understand each other they could
recognize they could recognize the the
commonality of their interests one on
one occasion and this is tremendously
insightful him in my opinion here is a
man who dedicated his life to free
Poland he dedicated and risked his life
to provide information to the United
States genuinely and sincerely believed
in the freedom that this country with
its system and the West represented and
yet for the longest time after he got
out it was very interesting to see him
speak with an American general officer
because they were astonished to learn
that he still thought they'd win because
as an officer brought up in that
mentality brought up in that culture of
Eastern Europe it was size that mattered
it was the number of troops on the
ground and barring complete nuclear
Armageddon he still had this basic faith
in the ability of the Soviet military
planning system to execute a massive
plan of attack against Central Europe on
one occasion we took him down to meet
with an American general and if you can
again imagine Poland here Germany here
Western Soviet Union over here through
the Western Soviet through Poland is
coming this entire strategic echelon I
can't I can't remember at this point how
many total armies that is armies are
made up of division of cores and cores
are made up of divisions I mean we're
talking about three or four Patton esque
sized units coming through Poland and
this American general because we're very
good at flexible footwork see this is
our self perception he said well general
Colonel kuklinski he said we're gonna
land a Marine Division right here on the
Polish Baltic coast and we're going to
attack you in the flank you understand
the point here they're coming through
here we're going to attack them from the
coast with a Marine Division Marine
divisions pretty big thing in the United
States and look what we're doing in Iraq
and Colonel kuklinski looked at the map
and the general says well what do you
think the response would be and kolinsky
said well probably nothing for three or
four days and this American general I
mean this is this was this was the great
the great move this was the great
flanking attack he says what do you mean
three or four days one why three or four
days he said well probably take us that
long to figure out that you were there
and then now we'd probably sent two or
three armies up to push you back into
the water two or three armies we talked
about a five six seven ten to one
advantage there was this issue of scale
this is this issue of planning and
lastly and I I don't want to belabor all
of this but our ability to recognize how
his mind worked to recognize how he
solved problems which was the result of
training and drilling and and and a
recognition of a staff concept that's
frankly absent in the United States was
absolutely key to our ability to provide
cogent pertinent and useful information
to our to our policymakers and finally I
don't close with the with the fact that
indeed this man was my friend he was my
friend he was my family's friend he was
a very very good man who I can assure
you suffered a great deal for the
sacrifice that he made for his country
he suffered because he was forced to
uproot himself he never had any
intention of coming to the United States
he had never any intention of abandoning
his Poland his idea was to live in
Poland to his last day he suffered
because of the of the the moral problems
that Ben has raised and which appear in
the book the question of people having
called him a traitor the question of his
having betrayed people who he believed
had already betrayed Poland to the
Soviets all of these issues vastly
troubled a very intricate and
complicated man and to a large extent
because of the fact that he became a
colleague rather than a used-car
salesman or a dairy farmer someplace
else in the Midwest his contacts with us
remained for the rest of his life and we
were able to deal with him through his
UPS and his downs and his emotional and
he was polish after all there is there
is there is being polish that that is
involved in this and Colonel kuklinski
was polish to the route my colleague Jim
Simon and I were much younger than he
and although I like to think that that
he respected us we were always always
aware of the fact that we were simply
precocious children and from his
perspective because as a good European
man his focus was on people his own age
and so we we worked with some American
army Colonels and some of whom worked
for the CIA who were his age his rank
and and and they had a different kind of
relationship because they could they
could share you know a certain a certain
maturity but I will tell you that that
it was a tremendous it's a tremendous
privilege that been involved as thing
from the beginning when it was a source
I will tell you that when and I felt
been this he knows I was called up one
day and out of the blue and said and
told that the the CIA had decided that
it was going to cooperate with some
reporter on the production of a story
concerning Colonel kuklinski and I mean
you could have knocked me over with a
feather
because I I assure you that at that
point in my life and probably still I
mention this to several others this
evening if you had asked me what the
last thing was that I'd give up as they
pulled the last fingernail it was going
to be that story that's how sensitive it
was held that's how important it was to
us and with the collapse of the warsaw
pact with the collapse of the soviet
union it obviously became something that
was much more important to share with
the public so that you can get an
appreciation of just how significant
some of this work is and how much it can
do to help protect all of our liberties
both as Americans and as citizens of the
world it's my great great privilege to
be here with the people who are actually
involved
in that operation on the hard part my
part was the reading and writing part it
was a tremendous tremendous thing if you
if you haven't read the book by all
means read it if you have read the book
take another look at it and recognize
the tremendous sophistication of all the
people that were involved thank you very
much since I am or was the case officer
I want you to know it's a unique
experience for me for the first time
after over 30 years to be talking not
only openly but publicly about Colonel
kuklinski and the Qt cooperation yes I
was a case officer one of many who
participated in the case and I would
like to give you in the time available
some of the impressions that I drew from
this experience that my colleagues did
and why it meant so much to us not only
to work with but to know to become
friends with Rashad kolinsky I'd like to
talk about several aspects of course the
man the source about the meetings we had
and about what in my view is the most
critical and important part of the case
and that is the internal successful
internal clandestine communications
exchanges with him over a period of more
than nine years in Warsaw handled by the
case officers of Warsaw
station let's start out with the first
introduction the when he came out to
Western Europe to Germany in the summer
of 1972 wrote a letter to the US
military attache in Bonn which led to
meetings in The Hague and in Rotterdam
Amsterdam I believe with two very fine
offices and one was the role of pulav
McHenry Colonel Henry and his partner
Walter Lang who spent four or five days
receiving this volunteer listening to
his story his identity or everything
that put together told us that here was
something that in effect was a case
officers dream the reporting on those
meetings was so good I studied it very
carefully when I was brought into the
case some ten months later and I felt
that I already knew this man quite quite
well I knew what motivated him he wanted
his country back why did he come to us
because there was no other country in
the world that had the the ideals the
the attractions of freedom and democracy
things that were very important to
richard kuklinski
and of course he came to us because he
was a military man and he knew that the
nato military forces were very heavily
american and he wanted to work out an
arrangement with the US army to thwart
the soviet designs invasion plans as
iris has explained to you so these these
reports that I studied were exceedingly
interesting in in giving me the details
of what his motivation was what his
access was
how how diligent resolute he was to
carry on what seemed to us to be a
long-term operation just what we wanted
so as I prepared to go out to see him
there was only one well number things
that bothered me such as Ford indeed
better not screw this up but one thing
that did bother me it was assumed I
think in headquarters that we would
continue to pretend that we are the US
Army after all he's a military man he
came to the US Army y-you know rocked
the boat and tell him we're not army
with CIA but there were several reasons
why I felt it was absolutely essential
to level with him the most important one
was the matter of integrity we expected
him to be honest with us
in everything he did everything he
reported we would have been disappointed
to find that he was not and by the way I
never spotted a trace in anything that
he said or gave us of fraud or wavy
truth so if we expected that of him he
had a right to expect the same thing of
us and if there was a momentary blip or
a blink when we told him maybe we could
there was a risk there maybe we could
get over that but we certainly couldn't
justify to him if he discovered years
later that we had deceived him for all
those years so this happened very
quickly and as it turned out he didn't
even blink
when I introduced myself as Daniel from
the CIA maybe he did blink but it was
just a normal healthy link
and I asked him years later if it had
bothered him when I told him where I was
from and he said no actually I'd heard
so much bitter nasty stuff about the CIA
from the organs the organs in Warsaw and
the organs in Moscow he said I figured
you must be a pretty good bunch of guys
so we met and I'll make a little
departure later but I'll tell you these
meetings were not you know let's have a
little small talk and we'll amble around
and you know what kind of drink would
you like and how is your hotel and
wasn't a hotel it was the lady of the
cruise ship we got down to business
immediately and that's another thing
that became clear to me not only from
the the reporting of the first year's
meetings but from the way he came into
the sort of shabby little safehouse that
we had in Hamburg he came to work to
produce to to advance the cause his
cause and by now he realized our support
of his cause we all meant business and
we worked hard and if there were short
intervals in which I was looking for a
note or Colonel Henry who was out was
looking at his receipts for the car
parts that he bought for Rashaad to take
back
well rashard would grab the microphone
and we had a tape recorder going and
would tell us things that he had wanted
to tell us but you know he hadn't been
time for that yet so these were intense
sessions and he would usually say I have
we'd asked him how much time do you have
three hours four hours before he had to
get back to the cruise ship and we would
we would subtract at least
45 minutes usually an hour from that so
that he would not have to go back in a
lather he would have time to study his
receipts and line up the car parts to
show that his guys what he'd been doing
and until the last minute or two minutes
when we would break out a little glass
of Linea aquavit for a toast
see the next day it was intense intense
work now a little departure here I was
invited by dorwan Wilson who is the
chief of Africa division in the early
80s to go with him to an Africa division
chief of station conference held in the
Ivory Coast and while I was there they
had done a lot in the Soviet used to
open target out there and I wanted to
thank them and tell them how things were
going and where we were standing one of
the station Chiefs came up to me and he
said you know I really feel sorry for
you guys what do you mean what guys you
bricks and sticks guys you know they do
internal communications behind the
curtain denied area operations sure you
have sources he said but you never have
that that thrill of being in a safe
house and you know talking things over
and some humor and no drink or two and
you know body language and you know
really you develop a warm association
that way and you know it also gets them
intelligence I said well look first of
all all of the people who have served
inside whether it's Eastern Europe or
their so beginning they've also had case
officer tours abroad so we know what
you're talking about
but the work is different there and yet
we we remember that our objective
is to collect intelligence and we'll do
it any damn way we can and if we have a
source who has access and we can't see
them out here in the Ivory Coast or in
Hamburg or some other place we will do
our very best job to communicate with
him effectively efficiently securely but
with humanity so he knows we are not
treating him just as a you know a
collector as a source and keep in mind
one thing I added usually we don't we
don't run networks we have a single
source here and a single source there
and all of them know or most of them
that we've dealt with they can't tell
anybody not their wives not their
friends anybody we're the only ones who
know what they're doing and so it is up
to us to if you want to call it body
language okay but it is up to us to
inject if it appears that that's
acceptable the human element into our
dealings with them and not just say you
know on the 10th you go here and on the
12th you go there and your last report
was fine keep it up and so on that's and
that's a challenge but we can do it and
we have done it and it's that last part
that I would like to dwell on for a
little bit yes the the meetings with
with Rashad took place in five years
successively from 1972 through 1976
every summer but before the 1977 trip
could be taken the general staff said we
don't need those anymore no more trips
and so for the last five years of of
retards work in Poland we did not
one personal meeting with him except in
the last awful horrendous week but also
keep in mind that most of the production
even in the first five years when we
were meeting every summer in in Holland
or Germany or Denmark
most of the with all of the documentary
production came through clandestine
exchanges in Warsaw
he didn't you know bring it out of shake
case out with him to to humble or heal
or any other place and during that
period five plus four and a half years
of four and a half plus five
Warsaw station turned over five times
there were two year assignments we had
in the beginning to offer two officers
at an assistant by the end of the 70s we
had three or maybe in some cases four
officers but rough count and during that
nine and a half year period there were
some 20 case officers who was sent to
Warsaw over what were already there the
first two or three when the case began
twenty case officers who knew they
better not screw this one up now about
ten rows here take one person eat and
intro on this side and one person in
each row on this side and think of
yourself in nineteen seventy three or
four or five being trained and sent to
Warsaw to handle this operation you
thought we all did but we were
determined to give it our best shot and
that best shot was the work of the
people in Warsaw who had an enormous
task to find in case and sketch and
describe and explain simply the
clandestine extreme
sites and to become masters and
doctorates in surveillance detection and
to establish normal innocent purposeful
areas missions trips excursions in and
around Warsaw that would not alarm the
surveillance when they when our officers
took those routes so that they would
have a large operational area to
potential area in which to operate and
hopefully without being swarmed over by
surveillance they also had in my view of
good good tradecraft possibilities which
had earlier been turned down by
headquarters as being risky dangerous
won't work forget it
and fortunately Karl Gebhardt who was
the first cos who worked this case in
Warsaw found those sites still in the
station files and used them and they
established the basic tradecraft method
that lasted throughout the nine and a
half years the the other ripples of
advanced technology tradecraft became
technical toward the end of the
operation and they were extraordinarily
valuable to us because for those of you
who've read the book you know that the
operation was compromised in the fall of
1981 it was not a tradecraft flaw
otherwise had it been colonel kuklinski
would not have lived as long as he did
he would have been grabbed it was not
his fault
he did not he did not cause the exposure
same consequence the same thing would
have happened then but there was
obviously some leakage of the material
that he had supplied to us but with the
Karl Gebhardt station chief bracket on
the on the front end and then three
other station chief Tom Ryan at the
climax end Warsaw station did a
marvelous job in this case and some of
its members here tonight and I salute
you it's it's hard for me to spend very
much time talking about this case
because Rashad and I as I can save as
oddish did he was not only a source a
project and operation a case he was a
very close friend and my last contact
with him was a rollicking ly good and
telephone call and early February just
after I come back from a little skiing
holiday in Colorado he was reading he
had already read the book he was reading
some reviews and they just pleased the
hell out of him and then we talked about
a lot of other things as well and
promised to see one another soon he had
stayed with me in early December when he
came up to Williamsburg where I live now
and had just drawn and amazingly well
not amazingly had a wonderful reception
from a group that came to a seminar
series conducted by Dick's dolt at
William and Mary College of William and
Mary there and I was it was Richards
last public appearance he left right
after that to
to Poland on his last visit there he
came home he was fine and as I say in
early February he was fine and when we
talked by phone and the next day he
suffered a massive cerebral stroke but
we know how we feel about him
I hope those you who have not read the
book will do so and thank you very much
your wife well I think you have had as
Ben said in his book a look at the face
of CIA as it was presented to at least
one person who sought out contact with
us I would just share one thing with you
which I think perhaps is more credible
now after hearing both kuklinski as seen
through the eyes of been wiser working
through interviews and records and then
also as seen through the eyes of the
people who actually dealt with him and I
refer to the eulogy that was given by
Jim pavatt at the ceremony at Fort Myer
and he made the point that early on
kuklinski was very intense man had the
idea of perhaps organizing something a
conspiracy or a coup or something of
that nature and I perhaps someone can
comment on that this evening
he was dissuaded from doing that however
he said you know in some ways
Kuklinski recruited CIA and I think that
comes out because you you hear of the
loyalty to the man the credibility of
the man and that his own driven desire
to save Poland and I think in many ways
see I did get caught up in that and in a
sense yes we can talk about that he was
a source and he was great help but in
some ways he recruited us so what we've
done is taking you through the case more
or less chronologically and from
different perspectives we left plenty of
time for QA what I would ask you let me
just remind you again Amanda okie our
director of adult education Nina Simone
that from our training staff as well and
they have a microphone so what I'd like
to do is just to ensure a balance and so
forth I'll help call and help call the
questioners I think it's harder for them
to see looking into the lights and we'll
try and be evenly matched here from side
to side so here's our first question
right there Nina
yeah please speak into the microphone so
everyone can hear you see which chapters
mentioned in mr. Rice's book as inviting
Colonel kuklinski for his first
appearance at the Polish Embassy where
he was presented a passport polish
passport after his rehabilitation
my question is I would like to get some
comments on your thoughts on the Polish
reaction to Colonel kuklinski as you
know the first reaction from Warsaw was
he's a traitor which is understandable
he was sentenced to death he betrayed
the values that values in quotation
marks that they held dear but that
situation became untenable and Poland
joined NATO after all he was as Biscay
said was the first published officer in
NATO subsequently however there still
ain't an element in Poland that is
downplaying his significance in his role
and still ongoing is the thesis that he
really didn't do all that much he didn't
have access to a lot of information and
he was just a minor
shuffler of paper obviously that has
been disproven by mr. Weiser's book and
by Jim favites eulogy at Fort Myer and
by what we have heard today but there
was one very bizarre incident which I
would like to get your comment on
several years ago a Russian diplomat
claimed that kuklinski was a double
agent and there was in fact working for
the KGB or the GRU I think it was and
where did that come from
and what would your comments be on that
I don't know where to start I think Ben
probably has the best insight into the
reaction in Poland but but we've got
time here so please chime in Harrison
and there have been as as many know many
critics of kuklinski in Poland starting
with the the former communist leadership
of Paul and many many people who were
not part of that leadership but we're in
the army and felt strongly that somehow
what he had done had betrayed the army
even if it wasn't the army that that
Poland should have and
Conte had been criticized and and and
and he one of his one of his most
frustrating things was he could not
often respond to that criticism because
he was living in in protected way in the
United States the Soviet criticism the
thing you mentioned is is true there
there were accusations of that it's it's
obviously ludicrous and and and I think
the records I examine demonstrate to me
that it's ludicrous but but I actually
find ludicrous to even think about given
how long the operation lasted and and
how much he did turn over to the United
States I will say that I think one of
the reasons there was criticism among
soldiers and officers was that there was
a perception that if kuklinski was a
hero for what he did what did that make
them what did it make the average Polish
officer or soldier who did not decide to
contact the CIA where they somehow a
traitor for doing that Kuklinski always
said he always told me and I know he
said ultimately in a speech that he
eventually gave in Poland that he never
thought that way and he did not think
that he in any way had put himself or
his mission above that of other officers
he merely saw himself as someone who had
made a decision about a route he would
take and felt that because of unique
access he had to the Warsaw Pact secrets
that it was something he could and
should do but I don't believe he ever
felt that every officer should have her
have even contemplated doing what he did
and I don't think he ever felt that they
had somehow made wrong decisions
necessarily that each had made their own
decision and it had made their own
choice so I think that's where some of
the criticism came from and some of the
uncertainty iris was he a double agent
if he was he wasn't doing a very good
job for them that's a flip comment but a
much more serious comment as as follows
there are two ways in which I can refute
that and one of which I'm going to lay
over to my my colleague in terms of the
normal kinds of reviews that take place
between case officers the Directorate of
operations and and a source from an
analytic perspective the most important
thing to understand is that this is not
some Tom Clancy novel it is not Jack
Ryan
upping in some place collecting the
information bringing it back analyzing
in himself writing the report bringing
it to the DCI drop flying out to a
submarine dropping down on the submarine
and talking to the Soviet command if one
person doesn't do all of these things
what that means is it's a very complex
chain of evidentiary analysis that
occurs regardless of how important the
single sources in the case of kuklinski
his information was certainly a
touchstone I seriously am not
exaggerating the significance of what he
told us but you must be aware that it
was never or rarely the only source of
information on such a large behemoth as
the Soviet Union the Soviet Union's
military target which was what I was
concerned with so there was ample
opportunity to derive absolutely
independent confirmation reassessment of
the material that was being presented
the material that he was presenting to
us came in two forms they were the
acknowledgement of Secrets which were
basic documents in which you know black
is described as black white as white
here's the plan that going left to the
going right there moving on the 10th
whatever and then they were the
mysteries which were the questions that
there are no specific answers to but
that general understanding allows you to
apply the context that I was referring
to earlier in each and every case over
the entire time that I used his material
and that I worked with him as a
colleague as when he came out there was
never ever any doubt about the fact that
what he was presenting to us was
objective and that my final point and it
reflects back on something that they've
said this wasn't an incredibly intense
individual but he was also incredibly
objective about the information that he
provided us it is a it is a problem at
times with people who are emotionally
motivated and intellectually motivated
that they confuse what they're trying to
give what they're giving you between
what they want you to understand and
what they in fact have learned
objectively with Colonel kuklinski it
was almost a textbook case of his being
able to filter out the kinds of
emotional content
that he might consider his own
interpretation and attempt very clearly
to define for us for us that this was
the specific information that he had
obtained this is how it was obtained
this is where it came from this is how
it worked and then we could go about the
fairly complex task of verifying that
and we did in each and every case I
would be well anybody would be
astonished to find a double agent I'm
sure so that might be a trite statement
but I've never seen anything to support
such a such a comment I'll so I'll make
one last point which was that perhaps
the the clearest piece of evidence that
would refute that was that in the very
first meeting that kuklinski held with
the CIA in Warsaw it wasn't really a
meeting he had met that previous summer
with some American army officers he
believed in Europe and set up the first
exchange of information in verse on it
was going to take place on a Warsaw
Cemetery and Karl Gebhardt who was the
chief of station for the CIA in Warsaw
set out on a long surveillance detection
run and eventually drove into the
cemetery to meet kuklinski there was
Colonel Klinsky in full uniform waving
to him saying Here I am I'm over here
and it was the stupidest thing he could
have done the worst tradecraft
and they and and and there was no way
the name had trained him to do anything
in the spy world who could ski was not a
trained intelligence officer he was a
soldier and he and he and that's how he
lived his life Dave one-one figure and
let me look for someone over here for a
question I will throw out one figure for
those of you have not read the book I
know many of you have not dealt in the
world of agents and tradecraft and so
forth but you know what a document looks
like the August paper being kicked
around by the 9/11 Commission is a
document in the course of Kuklinski's
relationship with us he turned over in
excess of 40,000 documents all of those
from obviously from secret files Amanda
okay let's how about one over here Nina
a couple of family related questions
first for Dave unless Fortin is that
really an Ellis Island version of Horton
Koski or something I think that you were
dealing primarily in polish and I wonder
if you might give us some background on
how you were doing that for Ben I wonder
if you might touch on Kuklinski's a
family situation where their parents or
wives or other folks that Ian sense had
to leave behind when he came out for
example I was in 1963 the third or
fourth choice to succeed bill Donnelly
as the chief of station Warsaw the other
guys wouldn't or couldn't accept that
job I'm happy they turned it down but
I've roared back from Argentina and into
ten months of intensive all day every
day most weekends most evenings study at
the Polish the daytime versions were at
the Foreign Service Institute and
Rosslyn yes and night time of course was
home and as soon as I could when I got
to Warsaw I went out and talked polish
with anybody who would talk polish to an
American diplomat and then there was a
second part to the question about the
family situation Aris were you what made
this case I'm more difficult for Coons
kids that he did have a family a wife
and two sons and they all lived in
Warsaw and we're not aware of the
specifics of what he was doing when it
came time at the end to try to rescue
colonel kuklinski and his family and he
was exfiltrated the entire family was
brought out and all resettled in the
United States under under completely new
identities
Oh Amanda yeah right here Davey touch I
touch him 47 years ago
could you yeah could you hold the
microphone up please
thank you in Poland and in America knows
more about cookies give not everybody's
buying a book are you planning to make a
film of it because this is something
that on television should be done that
people will learn about cookies and when
your book will be published in Polish or
is already published because people are
waiting for it it is being translated
and will be published in Poland I
believe early next year we some group of
poles at Arlington Cemetery and somebody
told me that is a kuklinski plaque on
the chapel or something does exist
something like this that poles told me
we have to go to Arlington Cemetery for
some Poland because it's something of
kuklinski at Arlington Cemetery is it
true he is going to be buried in Poland
yeah and I don't like to leave ok
alright one here Nina and then in the
back Amanda all the way back there up
here first
I met Ronnie of former arms controller
not about kuklinski but since you people
have worked with the yard shell Sookie
knows I might be able to shed some light
on a question which I have had in my
mind in the mid-eighties of President
Reagan sent me behind the curtain to
talk to Warsaw Pact people into the
heads of states of the Poland and
Hungary and Czechoslovakia then I go
down and brief the Pope and my question
is do you think there was any channel of
communication between Yara shell C and
the Pope either openly or
one was feeding the Pope information
from Warsaw I'll take a swing at that I
think somebody was feeding the Pope
information about developments in Poland
including preparations for martial law
law known as plan vo Snee planned spring
Carl Bernstein wrote about that in Time
magazine in 1992 or so and in his book
on the his holiness a few years later
the the critical meeting on Monday the
2nd of November 1981 at which Colonel
kuklinski to other Colonels and Generals
Clarkie were told we have it done by
General Starsky deputy chief of general
scoffs key said we've heard it from our
cousins neighbors meaning the Soviets
and that the latest version of the
martial law plan is in Langley and he
knew enough to say Langley and not just
CIA and furthermore that this is
information from Rome sources it was a
complete mystery to me to us there had
never been the slightest trace of of
ghul operational activity in Italy much
less leandro much less than the Vatican
there was no connection I don't think I
mean answer your question I don't think
material came from Warsaw where they're
from Janos else key or anybody else to
the Vatican I think maybe some material
went over there that shouldn't have gone
over there from our government and that
it was brought to the attention of Boris
solo Martin who was the KGB rezident
there one of their stars
and that he made sure it got back to
Moscow in a hurry and Moscow quickly
shared it with the polls you've got a
problem
you pulled I didn't mean to cut you off
don't you have nothing on the pope eros
hive Greek Orthodox I stay away Fred one
all the way in the back yeah I just
wanted to follow up on that there's been
as you were just getting into there been
a lot of debate about how kuklinski was
compromised and you just got into that
issue specifically there's been debate
about whether bill Casey personally
compromised it by providing information
to the Vatican about what kuklinski was
providing I was wondering if the CIA or
if any of you ever came to a conclusive
decision about how you think that
information got to the KGB or to the
Russians I'll say that in in the book I
do devote some time to the mystery of
that and and and describe David who
himself wanted to know and and undertook
an investigation to try to find out and
also even years later attempted to find
out by sending a friend of his a former
CIA officer to to meet with Sola Mata
and maybe I'll have Dave briefly
described that if that's okay but it was
unsatisfactory it certainly didn't
provide any real answers that confirmed
anything and and I personally don't know
so lahmacun had been pursued by an
Italian journalist in the early 90s for
an interview the journalist followed him
all solo Mountain all the way to Moscow
found him talk to him in Gorky Park and
then back at his apartment and wrote an
article for panorama which is a leading
Italian weekly magazine about what this
will amount in it said and so Lamartine
said he had four men of gold sources
three were in Rome one was out
at Rome one of the best ones was in the
Vatican now a good friend of mine who is
also in the book and who knew and knows
so lomatin and who was here tonight
went to Moscow after we had discussed
this and I said good friend please ask
solo marcin about that panorama
interview and if he has any things that
he'd like to add to your understanding
of it and of course Sola Watkyn told our
good friend who is here tonight that was
just a lot of rubbish that guy was on my
back I just made up stuff and gave it to
him and you know how to estar no offense
sorry case he ever asked by anybody
whether he was the size no okay she
didn't confide in me the question was
whether bill Casey himself was ever
asked whether he intentionally or
inadvertently had somehow provided
information to the Vatican and and I
don't know that answer right here this
colonel and yet you none of you have
talked and you mentioned that you were
trying to be human with him it you were
treating him like a human being and so
on yet none of you have mentioned any of
his innermost thoughts maybe about
religion did he have a family
he's like an atom so far I'd like to
know something about his family his
relationship and what happened to them
when he was extricated that sort of
thing it's a great question I only was
given 20 minutes though
the Klinsky was nine years old a young
boy in Warsaw when the Nazis invaded and
that's shaped his view of the world and
when the war ended and the Soviets moved
in that shaped his view of the world and
so for kuklinski the young boy Poland
was always being dominated by other
countries as he grew and and and entered
the Polish army he had a fervent sense
of being a pole and and and and and fell
horrible as he watched the Soviets
essentially take over and run the Polish
army as a Soviet as a subsection of the
Soviet Army
Kuklinski thrived and was brilliant and
a great thinker and writer and and and
and and was promoted and and he married
his wife Honka and their to sand and had
two two sons who who were teenagers
towards the period of the time of this
operation he he was a Catholic but not
but-but-but-but and I should say he was
an only an only child his father was a
member of the Polish underground during
World War two and was was killed in the
concentration camps and kuklinski went
in search of his father at the end of
the war and never was able to find him
so all this influence kuklinski the book
goes to do a lot of detail and he's talk
talks a lot about it but he was
ultimately what I loved about him and we
got to know each other quite well
because we began our conversation and
that apartment and rest in Virginia I
believe it was in 1992 and we continued
to talk until this year was that he was
an optimistic man he ultimately wrote to
the CIA in in 1981 shortly before the
exfiltration although he didn't know it
was going to happen at that point and he
was ruminating to David actually to
Daniel which is what he thought David's
name was as to as to everything he had
done over the eight or nine years and
and and how difficult it had been and
how fight he was leaving his home every
time he had to go out to make an
exchange with the CIA and said goodbye
to his family to his two sons and his
wife because he knew they didn't this
might be the last time he'd ever see
them again
and then how joyful he fell
as he returned home after making a
successful exchange or perhaps not
making a successful exchange as often
occurred to be able to get home again
and see them I won't give away
everything that's in the book but I will
tell you that that in this last letter
in in the fall of 1981 he wrote to David
and said despite all the difficulties he
was he had boundless optimism I think
were his words that he was doing the
right thing and that he would continue
to do so and that he was convinced that
through the acts of individuals and he
felt I might add much better about what
he was doing
given the Solidarity movement and what
it was doing starting in that period and
he felt he realized he was not alone
anymore in his quest and he felt that
through the actions of all these
individuals change was going to occur
and he was right I'd add to that you
know having seen him and and worked with
him later
he he as I tried to say earlier you know
had these these ups and downs he was an
emotional man it was not a person on a
cold calculating machine like person
this was a very warm human being who had
I can I can just imagine the scenes of
his his sense of impending doom and then
the tremendous release of having
accomplished the act and then starting
down the slide again because even here I
could watch him respond for example as
the gentleman asked earlier about the
Polish response to his activities and to
see his his emotional churning over the
question this is what I meant when I
said he was suffering he he suffered
over the question of of his not being it
not being universally recognized that
what he said he did he did for the
reasons he gave and so on and so forth
so this was a this was the kind of a
person who who you know was was just
constantly reacting to the environment
in which he was working and and not at
all a person who's sort of impervious to
outside influence there's a very very
warm warm kind of person ok other
questions yes right here Nina
duh y'all hold up for the microphone
thank you his reaction after the
exfiltration did you sit with him for a
while after he came out excuse me
it was in the States was it had a lot of
mood swings was he psychologically okay
during this tough period and we of
course met him at Andrews Air Force Base
when he came in security whisked him
away and did their controlled run to the
safe house I met him there shorter run
later on that day it was it was hard it
was very very hard for them and all of
us knew that and so we we had very good
excuses to bring this thing by or bring
this by or you know help them make some
purchases in the store or things they
needed we tried to do all we could to to
ease the shock of the quick extraction
and now a whole new society where they
speak a different language and there
were mood swings some of them have
caused by these reactions of theirs and
some of them unfortunately by some
thoughtless things that happened here
which I won't go into what we were
pretty vigilant I say one more thing
which is that you know what I was struck
by an in reporting the book and writing
it was despite and it's true there were
so many people involved in this
throughout the nine year period from the
agency's point of view in Poland in in
Washington and a slip at any stage could
have been fatal well said it was a very
lonely mission for him I mean he you
know Peter mentioned correctly that
there is a memo quoted in the book
roughly 40,000 Soviet documents were
turned over by kuklinski but that's not
pieces of paper that's actually clicks
of a camera each time over nine years he
was turning
rolls and rolls of film big rolls of
film of you know emptying the vaults of
the Warsaw Pact and and and this
material in each case was a single act
by him and so much of what he did he
couldn't confide in anybody and although
he do what he had done his family one of
the dramatic moments comes shortly
before the exfiltration when he has to
tell his family that they have to leave
Poland then this family you know which
adored him had no idea this was coming
he always had known this was a
possibility that they certainly his sons
and his wife had not I want to I want to
add one thing to just sort of take it to
a slightly lighter level it's watching a
person become an American Kuklinski
always understood freedom he always
understood what this place represented
but kuklinski never lived a day of his
life here until he was brought here that
day he'd never understood what it was
like to be here what it was like to live
in the system that we have and and I I
hope that you will take this as amusing
I intended to be but there's a there's
an element there's a part in in Ben's
book where he writes about the day the
morning after our encounter with general
gray when he got a call from his wife in
Washington at the hotel informing her
that for the first time he had been
exposed in the Washington Post in an
article that talked about this this
great this spy this defector this person
had been working for the United States
and that's and so on and so forth
didn't mention his name while it
mentioned his I think it mentioned is
his real name not not his his newly
assumed name so he was still secure but
he was outraged that this newspaper
would be able to publish this and so he
came over to Jim Simon and I was sharing
another motel room government rates and
bangs on the door and he says look you
know and and he'd gone out to get the
newspaper you know before we were awake
and then he came in and he says what are
you gonna do about this he said well is
not really much you can do about it why
not shoot him you know and
no you really can't do that here you
know sir why not am i is this as a
secret isn't it yes it's a secret he
exposed a secret Danny yes shoot him and
it took a few years you know for him to
fully completely comprehend what this
whole thing was about in terms of the
pluses and the minuses one right here
Nina yes Rani guys just won't put a
footnote to a lady and not have her feel
that the she should feel slighted that
there's no plaque there cooked when
sukhiya at Arlington Cemetery she won't
find one there she won't find a plaque -
Casimir Pulaski or to Titus Kosciuszko
either because no body other than an
American citizen can be born I mean can
be buried at Arlington Cemetery the only
plac you'll find there is to Ignasi on+
Sookie who died in this country 1941 and
President Roosevelt said bury him in
Arlington Cemetery and the secretary
then I guess he was coil in the
Secretary of the army today so you can't
do that mr. president because he's not a
citizen they will put him there
temporarily until fallen should be free
so you'll find a plaque at the mass of
the main at the arnfinn cemetery -
Ignasi on Paretsky
put there by President Kennedy who says
a here lies Ignasi on Petoskey
temporarily interred at Arlington
Cemetery
until Poland shall be free it was my
great privilege in 1992 to head a
committee which took other entities body
back to Poland I would just like to make
one point which is that Richard was
granted American citizenship after he
arrived here but in a talk he gave two
close friends including David that day I
believe he reminded everyone that in his
heart he remained a pole it was
interesting at the ceremony at Fort Myer
as we exited the chapel there was an
honor guard an American honor guard for
kuklinski Polish national
yes including a Polish national anthem
I've one question here one here and I
think that wraps it up guards we just
received word from Warsaw that his
funeral and internment will take place
on June 19th with full military honors
with an honor guard thank you
yes one question back here I guess for
Ben actually um are you still continuing
to research this story and are you
learning new things yet and did you
expect that that major revelations are
still to be expected well the book is is
the book and and you know I I think it
tells the story it's certainly the story
that kuklinski you know the story he
wanted to tell and and it's a story as I
said earlier that I think shows both the
human intelligence operation and in many
ways the human side of that as well as
the man himself and and his motivation
and and what led him to do that okay why
don't we I just like to first of all
take a moment to thank Ben wiser
eras papa state Fortin for a remark